[موسيقى]
المزيد من الغواصات زمن حرب المدافع
والذخيره التقليديه بوتين لا يضيع فرصه
المشاركه في مراسيم انزال الغواصات سواء
من الموانئ او من مكتبه
اخرى من الجيل الرابع تضاف الى اسطول
يتعدى 50 قطعه تاثيرها في حرب اوكرانيا لا
يكاد يذكر ومع ذلك بوت يطالب بالمزيد
تنفيذه سيتم تشديد اربع غواصات مماثله من
اجل تعزيز امن روسيا لعقود المقبله
فيلي كيلوت الغواصه السابعه من مشروع
بوريا غواصه نوويه من الجيل الرابع اهم ما
يميزها وقدرتها على حمل 16 صاروخا
باليستيا من نوع ار 30
صواريخ تعمل بالوقود الصلب ويصل وزن
الصاروخ الواحد الى 37 طنا اما المدى فهو
9300 كيلو متر يصل كل الدول بغض النظر عن
مكان الاطلاق
ذراع طويله تحرص مصالح روسيا في المحيطات
البعيده دخول كل غواصه جديده الى الخدمه
يعد انجازا يستوجب اقامه الافراح لكن
مظاهر البهجه التي شهدها حوض بناء السفن
في سان بطرسبورغ تحمل واقع موازيا وراء
الكواليس يوم واحد بعد انزال الغواصه
الجديده
الكسندربوزاكو مدير حوض بناء السفن الاهم
في روسيا يغادر الحياه الوفاه اعلنت بعد
ايام دون تفاصيل في الرابع والعشرين من
ديسمبر
الحياه فجاه الخساره لا تعوض روايه تتحدث
عن نوبه قلبيه من جراء تحديات لا تنتهي
لكن الاكيد ان البحريه الروسيه لم تكن
راضيه عن تاخر تسليم الطلبيات ضغط
العقوبات الغربيه لم يكن مقنعا من
الغواصات الى الدبابات يسابق بوت الزمن
للاستعداد لحرب يصفها بالوجود